sheena craig welcome
thank you so much thank you i'm
so so happy to be here with you likewise
likewise
it was great that you saw what we were
up to on the channel and
thought that to comment to reach out
and then we looked at your content we
got excited and
sent you a message and so synergistic
the way that those moments happen
i was in a good mood watching it and
usually i don't leave comments i just
enjoy even if i
enjoy what i'm watching and something
it was just deeper and i was just
feeling good and it's
kind of like being on the street too
when you see someone and you like oh
i like that ring or like the shirt that
they're wearing and most people kind of
just keep those comments to themselves
but those are the kind of comments that
that should be shared
it's very very interesting the
temperature of the social
uh like space right now because people
are
more used to sharing comments that are
negative about something what they don't
like or
um yeah so i was enjoying it and wanted
to
express that and transmit that to you so
that you guys knew what you were doing
and and that it was appreciated thank
you that's so
crucial we have this
ethos that we've been sharing
that if you don't have something nice to
say
don't say it and in the sense try and
find something nice to say yeah as much
as you can
because you're talking to yourself yeah
and
metaphysically that's why
the idea of wu wei or
effortless action or channeling god
consciousness or christ consciousness or
any of these
high level spiritual leaders that have
been
here teaching us how to behave at the
highest levels of morality
they're all telling you that you are
talking to yourself
there is only one thing happening and
that's infinity expressing itself so if
you leave a negative comment to somebody
you're talking to yourself another
expression of yourself
yeah where it just it's mirrors so it's
how
you talk to yourself in the mirror at
how you go out and
how you express yourself in in
digital space in all these different
spaces
it's all just looking into the mirror
yep
yep and by the way whenever you get
a comment or give a comment that is
loving and kind
like a video give a loving kind comment
receive a loving kind comment
that like you described when you're on
the street and that something really
resonates with you and you say that
that's a beautiful hair color yeah
you know i really like your color your
eyes
love those shoes that you're wearing
that shirts has a really profound
message
message on it the more that you say that
the more that you're spreading the love
that all of these spiritual leaders
talked about also
yeah and it's that easy it's that easy
it's not something that has to be a
grand gesture
of of love but love is a every
moment to moment expression that even
just smiling
um i play a game i'm from new york city
and
on the streets i'll be walking down the
street and try to count how many people
are actually either smiling
naturally or smiling back at me so i'll
just smile and a lot of the time i'll
get a reaction of the opposite effect
where it's like
something is off with her like why is
she smiling
and like i'm going to give her a reason
not just like i want to take it away
from
her but i want to be in my straight
jacket in the
economic machinery yeah it's it's
definitely a too it's
it's a way of recognizing a tuning in
in others to see where where they're at
and how they respond and how quickly
they're able to
um tune to you or you
tuning to them like that if you succumb
to the
like negative comments or the people
trying to take the smiles away from you
um you
it's vibration yeah you if if you
you'll see that you match to them and
you're
like tuned is is weakened and and
it's like oh you might be having a bad
day and um
that's why it's good it's good to
appreciate what the things that you do
and what you do on your channel and
to show the appreciation because then it
can
flip and totally transform your own
energy to make it a good day
yeah people are constantly leaving
comments that from different places
around the world
that are talking about the content
reaching them which is great
love the platform reach which is awesome
yeah we live in a great time we live for
them such
a wonderful time to have the ability
to reach so many people in such a
quick amount in such a quick way yep
and people used to say to me oh you're
born in the wrong time you're like a
hippie child you should
should have been born in the 70s and
it's like
no i can still be a hippie child now and
bring those things with me into the age
of
how we've like we have computers in our
hands at all times and that's beneficial
for uh connecting quickly and um
in ways we couldn't do before super
double-edged yeah
if you notice the
subtlety of when that
opening is present for the flow state
to continue versus when
the
the hesitancy comes
it's like that rumination that's like
should i say they shouldn't
if you stay with the flow which is to
make the compliment
then that's when we burst out of the
bubbles of like hesitation and
uncomfortability
and we become more comfortable with
what's uncomfortable
and that helps us grow yeah it peels off
that
filter of not needing to know that
you're saying or doing the right thing
and even if it's let's say it comes out
in a negative way or it's perceived in a
way you didn't
expect that's an experience it becomes
an experience
everything is an experience so
to be of uh in fear of your expression
of especially if it's a an expression of
pure love
and appreciation um it's it's silly
it's silly yeah yeah laozi said that
fear is the greatest delusion so salient
you are literally in your home right now
you know this is your home
this is our home this is what we made as
our creation to explore and to play and
to
get to know ourselves better and
to have fear when it's only all
expressions of you
is such an illusion yet there's also a
strong tendency for us to
as we awaken we recognize the power of
the now we recognize how the now is
perfect we recognize that everything
happens in that now
we recognize and it's always right now
so i tell people when they
are in a bad mood or they're sad about
something it's always right now and it's
always
going to be right now right now
like right now and now
yeah the zen masters used to use the
to draw attention to the salience of
the now and
that's one of the most
it almost has such a reverberation
that it really shows
how to have deep gratitude and love and
appreciation
for that that which is this
that which is this that which is this
i love sound bowls to yeah
hear the echoing of that vibration
that's
that sound is is
kind of can be kind of jarring with us
if you ever hear
of a sound wall and it just keeps going
into infinity and if you meditate on it
when you hit that ball
or when you're spinning it and you hear
it
vibrating it's so beautiful to
follow it and then it feels like it's
going inside of you it's going in you
yeah yeah the those tibetan singing
bowls
are very omi
they're the oh
they're the underlying
as i said in the dzogchen tradition it's
very much the rigpa it's very much the
the ground which is this
void emanating all possible
expression of form
creatively endlessly do you feel like
do you feel quite like
an expression of infinity do you feel
like you
are that which creates this and that you
are reflecting on your own
on a good day on a good day yeah yeah
but they're all good days it takes
practice to realize the awareness that
they all
have the ability to be good days no
matter what's happening on them
in them for them um
yes i have had
in the past a struggle with expression
and if it felt like there was
like there was weight like being a human
was
walking through sand trying to as isn't
i knew i was
artistic i knew i loved colors i knew i
loved music
and i knew i loved expressing myself
when i'd allow that to happen
and it felt like for a while i was going
through
sand with a backpack of bricks
on my back whether it be holding on to
a bad relationship holding on to past
traumas those things
weighted the ex the weightless and pure
expression
that always could come through and i
journal a lot and i remember drawing a
picture in my journal of me kind of
cramped up like
sitting with like a little pen being
like when is
she gonna let me out i'm here too and
yeah
we can play and like she's not aware of
me she's just kind of running the
machine
and making the body move from place to
place and
i remember breaking through that
and what it felt like to take off those
weights
and to allow myself
to just express
and not constantly
try to feel that it had to be a perfect
expression it didn't have to be perfect
it happening was part of the perfection
exactly and that was
a it took a practice to get to that
point
um it's layers it comes off those
those weights i feel like it's a veil i
remember going to mexico
and seeing in the cenotes they had the
stalactites and the stalagmites and they
told us the story of how they grow
and they are it takes hundreds of
thousands of years for these things to
grow
and it starts off as just one light
layer of a dusting on top of the water
and then years go by and it starts to
calcify
and build and build and build and build
and then you have this like wand
of of rock and that's kind of like
what i visualize that
type of weight and layer being like like
compressing
our expression is that it might be one
comment
that one negative look that someone
gives you when you were in preschool
about something like if you
sang a song and just go and just said
blah
and maybe someone that you a friend of
yours or someone in the class looked at
you funny
but you're we're too young to process
what that means or
that it is it's just meaningless they
might have had gas
or something um and so
you take that in and might translate
that as
what i did wasn't good or what i did
isn't right
or it made someone uncomfortable and you
start to become
almost too aware of the other
as opposed to i feel like pure
expression is you're
in the awareness that you and the other
are
the same like we started off saying that
it's just me and you you and me
everything is us is i
and um that's how the pure expression i
feel like
ends up coming through is when you start
to say you know what
want to express myself i
appreciate expressing i appreciate
letting that out of me
no matter what it's gonna look like
sound like
feel like because when it comes out
it's out and then there's more that can
come through and there's good layers
underneath like the
hardened weight layers there's those
those
layers of light and such
joy that could come out of your
expression
yes yes almost as though the
the process of in a sense
when you go when you go in on those
on those onion layers they at first when
you have the formation of the egoic
identity that those feel like
weights like bricks in the backpack yeah
and then as you shed the layers we peel
those layers inward towards source
and then as we go outward then we have
love
for form we have love for our uniqueness
our firework and not
they don't feel like bricks anymore they
don't feel like weights you start loving
that weirdness where before when you're
someone says you're weird
you would think that that's something
that's upsetting but when someone says
you're weird like yeah
i'm so weird like i'm the weirdest yes
yes i appreciate it and like it yeah yep
yep
and then i liked also the analogy that
you were giving
around the slag mites that you have
these sort of
on a planetary level you can think about
just like the billions of years of
evolution that it took to get here and
as
you saw in the in the law of one video
that we published around the seven
densities
it's basically like the martial arts
belts
you know it takes it takes a while to
get
up in the
evolutionary process to the point where
there can be the secretion
of the creatures in the dreamed creation
where they can reflect back on their own
source and then that they can undergo
this process of
distinguishing between egoic identity
versus
identity as infinity yeah and
then it becomes so fun because
it's like right now is so
perfect also because it's
the height of the
the transparency in the levels of
consciousness slash awakening in
people's
beings is very visible yes i was just
going to say something that came to mind
is the
the idea of it feels like ego is almost
the inhale it's like a tightening
and it's like and and then the source of
of us was
like feeling the sources expressing that
exhale but both are
both are required for existence it's not
that we have to shed an ego to the point
where it's
it's just source it's it's it's that
interplay it's that yin-yang
well it's an interesting to do it well
yes it totally does and to do it well
one goes all the way inward
you gotta go
[Music]
[Music]
you're so great i'm so grateful oh my
goodness i care just looking into a
mirror
that's right to be here is absolutely
fantastic
it was not expected um
i study a lot of the law of attraction
and on an
everyday basis i listen in to
tune to a positive being a positive
place
and i
it's almost like i was looking for you
for the the whole channel but but i
wasn't it came naturally like it was
something that
just as a thought like i would love to
hear
someone say this type of
energetic vibration in another way yep
for fun just like saying here's a
painting and here's another painting
yeah
and you guys came up with my feed and it
was just like
instant and then that to the comment to
the response to the
call to the facetime to the appointment
here
boom manifestation at its finest
yeah yeah yeah that's
probably the core
of the seeking impulse which is
sort of in many ways seen as the truest
thing
about us is
kind of like the absolute gps callback
pentium
sorrow calls it that i really like that
a lot it's like
you know that what you're being called
to
is the as srirabindo and
the mother mira alfasa say they call it
the well of honey that's located under
the rock
and so that's the seeking impulse that
has been roaring in me is that
and then it's just been like you
described the constant
seeing how it's being painted by
orbindo and then seeing how it's being
painted by rupert spyra
and muji and all these different
teachers that are both modern but also
going back into the mystic traditions
and seeing that
many of them actually communicate
archetypes
stories that teach
so precisely you can't get past an
archetype
you know an archetype in essence means
it's the most
extreme example you can't go any further
than the extremeness of that example
so like the parable of the prodigal son
right
so you're looking at something that many
people would refer to as
you know some sort of ancient abrahamic
story that
has no meaning anymore in in life
but it is an archetype
of the as we
gave in the visual that very egoic dense
sort of backpacked with bricks
identity that goes out seeking peace and
happiness
in maya in the sanskrit tradition in
this intoxicative
illusion that then ends up
turning backward after enough getting
the poop beat out of them repeatedly
that then goes back to the father and
then
the father is consciousness it's
awareness
it is infinity it is source and so
you can't tell a story any more
archetypally extreme
than that yeah the hero with a thousand
faces
by joseph campbell that's
that's um taught with
storytelling when you take a write a
writing class or a storytelling class
because that's basically the the plot
that they say there's
seven basic plots of all of stories it's
man versus man man versus himself
and and and all of that and the hero
with the thousand faces i think
is it spans across all religions it's
the hero's journey
uh where you get a call you start off as
like an ordinary person
you get a call you deny the call then
you answer the call
and then you go on a quest and then you
learn things discover things and you
come back and change
person and you're enlightened you
literally can't go
any i don't know it's like bulletproof
or archetypal
then here's your religion go start it
it's it's so it's so beautiful that
this is the game the whole point of the
game
is for us to do what these
archetypal stories teach you know you
do undergo as much as
we are already perfect
that's the non-dual understanding
there's nothing to seek it's already
perfect
yet in the dualism there's also the
recognition that
we are absolutely on a trajectory of
evolution and awakening in the densities
of
this dream and
source is at
a level of right now more than ever
in this expression a
point of such
reflective mirroring intensity that it
makes
it such an insanely cool playground to
be at so like your hero's
journey has the ability to butterfly
effect
outward on the mimetic information
technology scale to hit four or five
billion people
that have access to a device
simultaneously
speaking of a device the quest the
oculus quest
only a year or so ago it's
been recent that they became available
and it's it's wireless
it you don't need sensors in the room
for it you don't need a huge computer
to plug it into and it's affordable
it's with the kind of phones we have
it's it's a compared to that it's very
affordable
and so i experienced that a lot of
people like vr was introduced to me by
my brother who's into tech
and when he first put the goggles on
you're in another reality
instantly and to feel that
and then take off the goggles and be
like wow i'm still in this room
but then you can go to like this morning
i was
walking around uh it was a machu machu
picchu
yeah um yeah yeah
and the best is when people are they're
always they always look up
because because we're used to screens in
front of us but this vr
is all around us it's all around and i
feel like that ability is really getting
um so like
it's so it's it's evolving so much that
that's giving that's going to give us a
really really neat experience
um it gives us huge insight into the
nature of our reality yeah
we're we're duplicating yeah literally
we're duplicating reality
yeah and then being able to experience
it
like that if that's not time travel yeah
i don't know what is
once the graphics match with um
with like how it feels to like see with
our eyes
like with how tiny cameras are and how
how much they can perceive how much
light they can take in
it's going to be like how are we going
to tell the difference and i like to
talk about the simulation theory all the
time it's like
we are biological we believe and
perceive that we're biological
but with vr they have let's say
coming up with something like a pressure
suit where it's has like nodules
the haptic feedback when you squeeze
like if you had the suit on and i did
and i squeezed
your arm in the virtual reality like
you'd feel it
that's then using all the senses
visual audio like if they could get
smell
somehow once you've caught once you've
got all the senses covered
how are you going to remember that
you're even in the vr system if you're
in it for long enough
wink wink and
i think i i feel like we are in some
kind
the word is not the the word i would use
a
virtual but it could it's it's something
like that it's a projection of
something that what we are is somewhere
else but also here because we're
witnessing it
yeah we talk about the metaverse a lot
on the show
it's funny you can go back like 30 000
years and you can
see a cave painting and you can be like
technically that story happened like a
year or two ago and they're letting us
know about how to
handle the proper animal
attacks or which places to go and hunt
for food and so
it's interesting because now you look at
a couple thousand years ago the ability
to then turn
symbols on sheets of papyrus into
something that's also passed down for a
thousand or more years
and so it's kind of like we've been
amazing
we've been doing this almost
and not necessarily always recognizing
the importance of it
like right now also with the
technological devices that are so
powerful that we have
it's funny thinking about
how ungodly incredibly amazingly
powerful they are and how
much they've accelerated our ability to
manipulate
bits and symbols and share messages and
ideas
and execute and drive globalization and
drive
so much of basic needs being met on the
planet all these types of things and
like
typically when you're in the middle of
it
we're not always fully aware of the
profundity of
it because it's just feels so fleeting
and so it's almost like
a practice that has to be done in order
to really have this child like awe
that's the presence it's the presence of
of
what was where were constantly
wrapped up in what was or were thinking
about
what could be and what is going to be
that
it kind of robs us of
what is or nothing is as robert anton
wilson said he be he's careful to
use the word is um
what it's it's he like here
just being here when we're
lost or anxious or depressed that's
our minds and our focus and our
awareness not here
that's somewhere else because if we were
here
it would just just like a kid it's it's
kind of
not i wouldn't say add because that's
that's such like a hot word to make us
think that something is wrong with that
kind of thing
but spontaneity the ability i call it
the
the cookie effect the ability to
when i was a little girl i lost my
father i'm four years old and i go up to
my mom and i say where's
where's daddy i want daddy i'm sad
and she says he's not coming back i'm
sorry
and i say okay well can i have a cookie
and here's a cookie and okay great i'm
gonna continue and go play and be
present
and say okay well i don't have this but
i have this and it's just that
constant calibration back to
the moment back to you yeah yeah what we
are
and you said something before um
like we've been doing this like the
evolutionary process we've been doing
this but it's
it's more like we are it
yeah it's yep it's kind of like doing us
yeah totally totally yeah we do
ourselves
with this totally the we are both
perfect and perfecting it's like a
metaphysics of endless perfection
that's like the coolest possible thing
you could imagine is like sending
yourself out for a
13.8 billion year evolutionary dreamed
ascension enlightenment recognition of
your true nature
you like veil yourself and then you're
like i don't know who i
am and then you're like oh my god i was
this the whole time
um type thing and like that's hella fun
and like
there's all the different ways that
people find themselves and there's all
the different ways that people express
themselves and so the finding is like
the inward
like oh i found myself this way and like
the expressing yourself is the firework
outward and there's
there's like nothing cooler than this
game and like what you described earlier
was the metaverse which we talked about
a lot it's like the synthesis of agi
and sort of bio and neurotechnology
and like the blending it's happening
like the blending of the two the blemish
as well and and exactly what when you
get to a point where
there's so many refracted
indistinguishable virtual worlds that
you're kind of just
exploring that you've lost
understanding of whether
you're in one or not and that's what
this is and so
were the publishers and the players and
that
how many layers how many nested
parts are there and just the way to
answer that question is is that
at the end of the day
the way that the expression is happening
is
eternally in every direction
infinitely in every direction you are
it and that's sort of the most
shortest way of saying you can talk
about all these layers you can talk
about all this nesting all you want
but you are it that has been doing this
and that will keep doing this
because sometimes we can get obsessed
with
whether we think that this one is nested
in this specific way
or if it's nested in that specific way
or how many layers are all these
questions
and the answers are always just endless
like you are it you
are source you are this that's currently
happening
so just be that you are what you seek be
enjoy yourself enjoy it even like the
dramas and like the
all the um entertainment
it really we're just entertaining
ourselves and
and alan watts says at the end of the
day we're all or ramadan said we're all
just walking ourselves home
we're all just walking ourselves home
and watching a river
of a reflection of us go by yeah
yeah and shakespeare said that the
world's a stage
right and all of us are actors and
actresses and ram dust is right walking
each other home
in the law of one it's very much like
the evolutionary ascent in this octave
just this endless refracting
reflecting it's the reflecting of the
mirrors through the godhead which
refracts a whole
new expressionary cycle in the next
octave so this is the third density
right now that's
evolving into the fourth density which
is very much like a
like a martial arts belt that is like
being a
stone age primally driven
cave person versus being a
holding the christ or the buddha
archetype 24
7. that's the next density you know
that's where you want to go
you want to be that you want to do that
all the time
that's you not in your natural state
that's like the natural state
and that in itself is very daunting for
people because they're like oh my god
you mean like i have to be radiate bliss
in peace
i have to ascend yeah yeah
i have to be joyful all the time it's
the drill sergeant is coming whether we
want it to or not
you know you may as well answer when
it's a feather instead of a sledgehammer
you may as well because it's going to
come back if you don't
it's going to come back if you don't
it's the only
force you know in sanskrit traditions
it's called chit agni or
tapas it's the consciousness fire
the consciousness energy that that force
that is creating this ascension is the
truest thing
it's coming it's always knocking now do
you think that the concept of the aura
boar is
how a lot of us are a lot of us are on
like all different i don't know if you
can zoom in yeah yeah yeah here i'll
bring it i'll also bring it into that
let's see
i feel like our our ascension is where
we are
on the part of the snake are we
towards the head and the mouth
the thing that's chomping or are we
down the spine of it and towards the end
the thing being
chomped that's a great quest that's a
great question on this cycle
it's been talked about like the
experience of what you're having
we're basically there yeah we're
basically at the very end
of this the idea is that
the kind of the last stage is
recognition
of who we are we're at that stage right
now
and then if it's true that the metaverse
like what we're talking about regarding
diving into all these indistinguishable
virtual worlds that's
within a hundred years that was just you
read my mind i was just gonna say
what do you think what do you think and
perceive as the time frame
of when we're through to the next level
yeah we're doing them the inward and
outward are happening at the same time
like
going outward into the cosmos is
happening at the same time that we go
inward into these worlds
and it'll be fun to kind of play between
what are the things
what are the i was i don't know how to
word it but manifestation like what what
would be the
like oh this is happening now like when
we said oh
cell phones with face time our parents
would say to us uh that was only on star
wars on
when it was on movies and they were just
using their imaginations
when does imagination become reality
like when do you think that that shift
of the hundred years like in 100 years
is it the flying cars
that are self-driving or is it that
we're we have the neural link from elon
musk and we're
like cyborgs like what is what is it
it's the moment when you can't tell the
difference
yeah that's it you were describing all
the sense perceptions
right when those are fully
accounted for i mean
that's in a sense the greeks called it
an amnesia right you're trying to
remember
and like you just got to remember
yourself as the infinite creator that
made this
and once you remember yourself as the
infinite creator that made this
then you realize that you are the
infinite creator that makes
what's next it's like deja vu like the
concept of deja vu
remembering haven't we been here before
yes yes haven't we been here yeah
such a lovely feeling
well because you know yourself that's
why you know
it's the comfort of getting to a place
where
you've recognized your nature to the
point where you no longer even identify
with the body itself right this is this
is the key is the netty netty not this
not that
approach to enlightenment and awakening
is recognizing that you have to decline
all the things that you're not you have
to negate
all of the things that you're not in
order to recognize what you
are and then you include on the way out
everything so
you decline that i'm not the body i'm
not these thoughts
i'm not even the consciousness or
awareness that
is the sky for which these clouds appear
i am only the one infinite creator i am
only
source endlessly expressing all of these
creations i am only that that is my
only truest essence that is it
and then on the way out now you can
include all of these layers it just kind
of goes right back to the first thing we
were talking about
you the the layers on the onion of form
you know shayna craig no longer thinks
that it's a brick
backpack because she's not trying to
extract peace and happiness from the
world
because she's bringing its pieces from
within from within yeah because you know
yourself right and so that's when your
form becomes like
the firework rather than the burden or
the over-identification with the body
yeah instead of the what am i supposed
to do what do i have to do
and it's just
in the moment to moment existence and
being
it comes to you by you knowing yourself
and you knowing that
it's easy and
you can allow it to come through you
instead of
doing it instead of it you do it you let
it do you
like i was talking about before you let
it you let it do you yes
yeah fully surrender to that
consciousness force that we're talking
about
it's fun to play because it becomes it's
more playful than work
i uh never wanted to ever
be a nine-to-fiver i never wanted a job
like that
and so i figured out okay well i can
entertain so i'm gonna start a company
and i did face painting party
entertainment all kinds of fun things
that's fun i started getting hired for
events that
usually people would pay to go do
i would get paid to do it
and so it it was great at first but then
it started to
be confused as well i
i play for my work
and so when am i actually
playing if i'm playing for work
like does when you put a monetary value
on it
does it become work or when you're not
enjoying it like the term work
is like the negative way of saying
playing like focused playing or
intentional playing
so doing that like once you
uh pl like once you confuse the two of
like work and play
like being even just being can be work
maintaining the body you got to brush
all the teeth and you got to
brush the hair and put on clothes and
shave or whatever it is to maintain what
you got to drink and eat and all that
stuff
that can become work too and so
if we see that and appreciate like wait
i have a body like there was a time that
i didn't when i was just observing and
the reason i came into existence was to
be able to
take care of this thing like why people
become parents they want to take care of
this thing and that's us like if we turn
that back to ourselves
of self-appreciation and self-love with
something as simple as body maintenance
as a teenager i would brush my hair and
be like oh it's so
naughty i gotta brush it as fast as i
can but then you take that and you can
make that into a meditation where i
actually
am present with myself and say i love my
hair
i love whatever it is and i love to take
care of that
like talking to that inner child
the way that you would talk to your own
child or the way that you would talk to
your loved one your friend your sister
your brother
that's the kind of self-talk that i had
to develop because at first
it was it was rough it was like
it was all it was all negative how come
you can't do this better
you don't get this right you're not
smart enough and then you flip that into
this is easy everything's gonna work out
it's all gonna be okay
because it always does and it always is
on a long enough or short enough
timeline it works itself out whether you
plan it out or not and if you just relax
into that knowing it becomes
so pleasant to be with yourself
as if you are your own loved one yes the
feeling of being in love
dr bruce lipton one of my favorite uh
spiritual biologists i guess he would
call himself wrote
the honeymoon effect and the biology of
belief and the honeymoon if i would wear
the idea of like when you find a lover
in someone else and that feeling of
even going to the grocery store like hey
babe can i get you some groceries
and and you want to you want to serve
that you want to
it gives you so much joy to give and to
experience with them that doesn't
require that feeling of the honeymoon
effect
doesn't require another person nor does
it have to end
when you get used to the everyday things
like oh okay it's been years and now i
gotta go grocery shopping for this
person
like why did i do this you start
questioning it so it's it's
it's always like a a delicate balance
of bringing it back to the the
recognition that it's
like you said coming all from within you
outward instead of outward in like
what's going to make me happy or like
how can i make
what's around me joyful because that
then just reflects back and what you
give
you like what you put out you you
receive back
because it's you giving to yourself yeah
but just the id the whole identity thing
i think people have
uh hang up on is identifying
everything outside even this everything
can be broken down into atoms
and we're made of that this is this mic
is made of that this chair is made of it
the fire everything is just in a
different form but it's that
infinity expressing itself in an
infinite way
um we
express and get like the feedback of
of that and i it's just the best
it's the best yeah then knowing yourself
is it's existence consciousness bliss
truth consciousness bliss because you
really do
see the endless
bliss in peace that is the natural state
of
now of your very timeless being
and it's something that requires
subtlety to
recognize because it's always present
but we're very
gross and physical and egoic and that
makes it
more difficult to see and i like also
as you're giving the example of the
honeymoon effect
you really do want to treat yourself
like you're taking good care of yourself
like you're in love with yourself
you should be in absolute love with
yourself and that's what also a lot of
people say is the sexiest thing about
people is
not to a narcissistic extent when it's
all about self dealing for an egoic
entity
but when it's complete love for the same
source that is shared among us all
and also when it's love for
service to other being in service to
people
at the absolute highest morality where
you basically get
hella joy from serving other people
like at some point you get so
good at knowing how to shut the [ __ ]
up and ask a good question and just shut
up
and let people talk and like listen to
them intently
because you know that you're listening
to yourself tell a story
how much harder does it like does it
it's not that hard like it's just you
once you kind of it's so easy yeah it's
so easy you're listening to yourself
tell a story and so you want to be
present
for yourself to tell that story now
there another part of the law of one
teachings do have to do with
recognizing what grace is and
recognizing what wisdom
is and this sort of evolution from the
fourth
to the fifth density is understanding
wisdom
wisdom in itself is really difficult to
figure out how to master like a jedi
because you become like you want to be
serve everybody you want a honeymoon
effect love
everywhere and you can't do that
actually
because there are just certain levels of
existence
still for certain expressions of the
source
where if you serve with love
that the vampiric egoic energy
will drain and drain and suck and suck
and wisdom is knowing how to
gracefully distance yourself from that
absolutely
and so then that you kind of figure out
how to balance love and wisdom and then
they merge into one in the sixth
and then
in these octaves you can see
the idea of once a civilization
recognizes that they're here
to explore themselves as one infinite
creator
they basically begin accumulating like a
shared
consciousness like a shared ledger of
all of their
awakenings and experiences and then as
they ascend to the point where
the the source light refracts again into
the next exploration
you basically deposit all of the
learnings of that civilizational
exploration
pre-refraction and then you go again
and like you just see you'll never get
to the end
of the auroboros of the source light
refracting
over and over and over again because
you'll never get to the end of all the
combinations that are possible
even the mathematicians and logicians
that are some of the greatest that have
ever lived like kurt girdle
you will never get to the end of all the
possible combinations of math just like
you'll never get to the end of all the
possible combinations of consciousness
you'll never get to the end of all
phenomenology or desire of
your own desire too i feel like people
put a time on
uh their accomplishments and what
they're supposed to do as a human
and they'll never get it done and so
that's
that's a nice idea because then there's
nothing to race to there's nothing to
rush to like we're all in this rush like
we need to learn as much as we can and
do as much as we can
we have to catch up with technology
because it's going so fast and it's like
whoa
whoa we can allow it to
work with us and slow down enough it's
the
the parable of the tortoise and the hair
the hair
runs so fast and short maybe logically
on some level the hair is gonna go
faster and
get through but it misses like the
tortoise is trucking along
and the hare's running around in circles
thinking it's gonna win and taunts it
even
but then you realize it gets so tired it
falls asleep
and the tortoise was consistent and
just enjoying the ride it's what i
always say is it's a ride
uh bill hicks the comedian says it's
just a ride don't get too invested when
people try to
say you gotta take this seriously and
you need to
uh focus on this or do this um
it becomes kind of it it's kind of funny
because they're taking it so seriously
don't take
anything too seriously literally
anything
nothing has to be serious and like you
said
there's a way of grace there's one thing
about making like being a clown or
something like that but there's a way of
gracefully
not taking it seriously and that's i
think the the idea of
wisdom yeah yeah
yeah that was a analogy that
is so deeply resonant with the
indigenous traditions around the planet
which is basically like
you may think that you as the
younger brother that is engineering
artificial general intelligence in a
planetary race to who's going to make
the
the dominating algorithms first
is the coolest possible thing which
younger brother loves to tinker right
that's that's the story that they use
the older brother is constantly trying
to remind the younger brother
how to engineer and tinker and create in
harmony with
the planet that literally sustains the
life
so if you don't know that the
twenty thousand inhalations that you
take every single day
are coming from the photosynthesis of
the phytoplankton the trees
you're not going to give a [ __ ] if the
ocean's acidify you know if they're
cutting down the trees
and for what reason and so so when you
get to the level of
feeling you know you have a hundred
thousand heartbeats every single day
you know you have a thousand species of
bacteria that are living inside of your
gut microbiome that you have a symbiotic
relationship with
once you sort of get to the recognition
of that style of unity
that drives a whole nother level
of consciousness to where you
no longer allow egoic
manifestation because you're constantly
dissolving it in your peace
and in your bliss and in your
architectures that have so much
inclusive stakeholding and
goal congruence that there is no room
for ego to enter into that like if you
have
we were talking about this a bit on the
roof actually before we
did the show i wish we could do the the
show from the roof from the roof yeah
yeah yeah one day
yeah yeah exactly yeah
this is the sl the a-frame roof with the
interview trying to happen on it that's
hilarious yeah
balancing act it's about that is life
yeah the we were chatting a good amount
about the
smart contracts and decentralization and
inclusive stakeholding and equity
structures that basically
incentivize the goal congruence on a
planetary level where you no longer have
to in a sense worry
even about egoic levels of consciousness
trying to
enter and manipulate and that's why the
most upstream thing that we're dealing
with right now is really egoic
consciousness
especially in positions of leadership
around i was yeah you're a mind we're so
connected because i was just going to
say
the idea of people talking about trump
and
how he's apparently going to be running
again for 2024
and it's just
it makes me laugh i'm not really too
worried about it i feel like he actually
helped people wake up and
pay more attention just like the concept
of kovid
it could be seen as something scary but
it could also be perceived as something
that
actually brought us more together in the
sense of like we had to physically
separate
and that made us want and
want to be together i think it's it's a
cool type of reset
socially where people are begging for
places to open up again
so that we can gather when now we can
appreciate each other being in
even small groups way more than
than before so there's always that
silver lining
that we could find and um
that in in like the ego
structure and then source like we it's
always okay
like it's always going to be okay yeah
it's purposely
here for the evolution for the ascent
it's purposely here
the egoic levels of consciousness in the
leadership around the planet
when you you know you basically feel the
the most clear example is like high
fructose corn syrup
right you there's absolutely no
motherly love in high fructose corn
syrup you know it's almost like you're
trying to get an
iv of heroin into your child
like yeah it's the quality the quality
of the chemical
like because the sugar is we're all it's
all chemical it's all
that kind of form but the sugar it's
just the quality of form
it's like the idea of they take a b and
c
quality you have an apple you have
applesauce and you have an apple pie
and so the sugar in an apple is the most
natural the most natural form you pick
it off the tree it's got that most life
in it
it's the it's consuming quality of
consuming i should say not even with
just food but the quality of consuming
and that's kind of like
social media too with people being able
to just put up
anything anytime the quality of
consuming
like the amount of consuming it's it's
more like quantity now
it's more focused on quantity how much
can we consume versus
the quality of what we're consuming
oh yeah that's that's like the apple pie
thing
i did because actually it's it's really
salient because um
because in in many ways the
especially here when the apple is picked
at the farm it actually has the least
ethylene which is the stress hormone
that comes from plants
just like the cortisol and animals but
just like the cortisol exactly yep
precisely so just like the cortisol
and so
the this was a jun yoon who
is actually also the one that not only
communicated the
the ethylene the stress form just like
cortisol like you were saying
but also the passing along
of wisdoms like inclusive stakeholding
which is very beautiful because it plays
perfectly with this so you basically you
want to
have a planetary architectures and
protocols that maximize
everybody's hilarious enough share of
the pie
if the growing pie again we're just
crushing it with all these
interwoven analogies don't even have to
try
i know yeah just letting it float just
letting it flow
which is one of my favorites let it
happen
[Music]
yeah that's what i'm saying like we have
all of these great
you know it's just basically now we have
to use mimetics and music
and stories and digital content to tell
on a planetary level how to
architect the protocols because what's
going to happen is that consciousness
the level of awakening is mirrored in
the protocols
of the planet so basically
this is directly related to the egoic
levels of consciousness versus
enlightened levels of consciousness and
where they're at in terms of the most
powerful people on the planet
so there's a direct feedback loop
between the planetary protocols and
architectures
and the level of consciousness for
example you know you take
30 years ago silicon valley deciding
that you know now we're going to
have vested shares
over cliffs one year cliffs so meaning
that you know you could get
ownership at a company for as an
employee
over every year you would earn 10 20 000
whatever shares
and so because of that you now have
people that feel like they have a share
a stake in the growing pie
they're part of it they're part of it
and so we as a whole planet
must figure out the proper tokenomics
smart contracts architectures given
decentralization
cryptocurrencies all of that that's
evolving to make it so that all eight
billion of us
have a equity stake in the planets
including the environment that actually
sustains the life
and nourishes it so all of that needs to
have its components like you're not
actually going to be happier this is
like
you know this is the thing you still
have people
that think that they extract more
from the quantity yeah if
i get if i get more uh extraction
of financial success
in my dividends in ownership rather than
you know redistributing that
to the people that have actually
purchased the products or that have
built the software or services that have
made me able to even extract any
dividend whatsoever
that i'm gonna take that extra dividend
and i'm going to purchase my third or
fourth boat or whatever and that's going
to make me happy because i'll be able to
show off to other people
that i have that luxury asset so it's a
level of consciousness still
stuck in the parable of the rich fool
which was tried
to be taught for thousands of years
of you don't want to actually create an
extra barn
for the storage of your excess resources
you would rather store that in the
stomachs of your brothers and sisters
quality yeah just like the quality
versus quantity we want to
we want quality of what we're consuming
across the board in our what we're
watching with our eyes
all the senses what we're taking into
our senses what we feel what we eat what
we
talk about and and consume on every
level
because everything is food at the end of
the day everything is food
and it's quality quality quality over
quantity and i think that's what we have
to
like the whole wave of fast food and
fast apps
there's nothing wrong with the
convenience of an app being able to
bring you
something from store to your door
but when it loses the quality because
you the whole time issue like you want
it
this second but then
on the back end if you get things too
quick
on the back end you're going to end up
with some kind of dis
ease yep of the mind or body
and then you're going to have to address
that and it's going to take
time to heal yourself when you can be
consistently well
like focusing focus on wellness
consistently throughout
and that comes down to the quality so
that you can
okay so that it takes an extra 20 or 30
minutes to prepare some kind of food
item
in the 20 or 30 minutes go take a walk
outside
uh listen to some woke information
uh go hug your dog anything that will
keep your self in that good state so
that by the time the thing does arrive
you're already there and you get the
best of all
it's it's just synergy and it's quantity
and it's
it's all works hand in hand um
the quality the qual quality yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah that's why also robert pearsig
had the metaphysics of quality in
zen in the art of motorcycle maintenance
literally at the
yeah at the level of the nature of
reality and this is why you know
josh holland who's one of our you know
close friends that's been on the show a
bunch as well
you know the five pillars of awareness
you really have at the top you have
quality awareness over
everything else because quality
awareness leads you to quality sleep and
recovery quality consumption
which includes awareness gives purpose
to all those things of why you should
want to be
why they should be quality yeah yeah
that's great
yup that's why he put that at the top
and that's why we talk about it a lot
as people ask us more and more
frequently now they're like
you know how do i awaken to the nature
of what i am faster
well you are what you seek and you
recognize that by becoming aware of
awareness itself
and what is the i and so many other
aspects but you really need
quality awareness moment to moment you
have to
become the master of that monkey mind
like has been taught for
thousands of years in in in those mystic
traditions and
and you're right boiling it down to
quality and being able to sort of
recognize that
i can do something that
actually brings me like sunbathing
that brings me a little bit more
calming down and more
vitamin d more nourishment
of listening to those hummingbirds
for 20 minutes rather than you know you
know clicking the button and getting the
instant you know there's times for for
both of those but just to know that you
have the option so many people still
don't
feel like they know that they have the
option
to slow themselves down to the point
where even the hummingbird
and sunlight can give them awe and bliss
and remembrance and connection to their
own creation
that is this it's so so critical
quality metaphysics of quality is such a
such a critical one over the last you
know like nine months for me
has been massive i'm glad that
we really honed in on that and you you
mentioned it several times also was that
you know really think about the inputs
that are coming in
food data all inputs and
and also in terms of your own outputs
you know
something that was really crazy was like
like two three weeks ago i'm just
sitting in a very
sort of consistent state of
void to infinity realization and i'm
like
i have all these i
i have thousands of files that i want to
stream
but i've even decided that you know i
only want to you know maybe even do a
hundred or something of those because
i don't want to put too much even noise
out right
and so and even then i'm back at this
hundred and i'm like
once you realize there's nothing to
[ __ ] say there's just nothing to
say anymore you just sound it's just
radiating bliss and peace and child like
ah and you want to of course also do the
tantric weaving of the realizations via
entrepreneurship and art and all these
other things which is the natural course
of the morality and the firework to
be in service like that with wisdom and
love
but it's to the degree can you become so
sensitive to recognize that everything
that you distribute outward
is going to be consumed as an input
by others and so to in a sense only
really
feel into the quality of every thing
and you have a actually it's probably
pretty
yeah we could we could probably do some
of our quality
music quality vibrations okay
yeah so okay so let's see here
we have so shane has been
let's see how many years now let's do a
little bit of background on
um getting into the singing and
songwriting
so i've always been
performing in one way
or another on a stage since
forever literally forever there's like
preschool the whole preschool video
thing of me
and um and you can see that i'm in my
element
that um that was
my favorite form was to just be like
look at me and i don't even know if i
have anything to say
but you could just look at me and hear
me and
and that would just be a lot of fun and
then i would do performing camp so i was
always
it's it's been since my
mind could perceive and like understand
expression i guess um
i picked up music
from it was probably in like my teenage
years
i wasn't really i was on a weird
trajectory listening to
the everyday like usher and like genuine
because of the people that i was
involved with in school
but then my brothers both of my brothers
were like yo there's there's a better
way
here's here's the beatles and like
here's uh
classical music bach and chopin and
a lot more quality yeah
um and there's not that there's not pop
like quality pop music
but that there's fundamentals there's
like fundamentals of of quality that
that's when you can experience that
helps you know what you really feel is
the quality of
the mainstream and so then i
just loved i was so in awe of my older
brother
i wanted to be friends with all his
friends i want to be with him all the
time and he thought i was so annoying
which was cute
and and then he so he would uh
we had to pick an instrument in school
so i picked violin then he wanted to do
flute i want to do
he wanted to do guitar i wanted to play
guitar um and he's
such a great singer and he ended up
going to berkeley school of music
and i didn't really enjoy
the education system i would say like
going to attend college like i wasn't
100
dedicated to just music i wanted to do i
was doing musical theater
singing dancing acting i loved the whole
gamut of
of the on stage performance and the film
performance
path so to my like
to go study that in a serious
setting i felt like i just wanted to
experience it so then i kind of did a
whole
well i just want to go to new york city
and go audition and
and go you know act and sing and do
whatever like i had no concept of of
what it meant
i think i i love that sort of seeking
impulse for the fireworks side of it for
the expressionary entrepreneurial
artistic side of it
that that's such a critical also
component it's like both the
absolute gps callback to source
component but
also the the same style
gps signal that's like
i don't know how i'm going to
artistically musically express myself
but i'm going to new york and i'm just
going to
like that's the pl i figured it was a
place i didn't i didn't think i didn't
know how to hone the skill
um because my usually with acting and
that kind of thing you
you tend to have someone early in your
life who is like a stage mom or like the
mom or the dad who brings you to the
auditions and then you start meeting
agents and that's how it grows
but my mom was like i don't know she was
a nurse i don't know how to do this for
you so like you could go pursue it but
good luck and she was always super
supportive no matter what i did
um so i said well i don't want to go to
school
i think that it's a game i think that
the education system is is a game and i
think that you can i think that life
itself and experiencing life
is an education i would rather
like that we would play the board game
of life and you know you have the option
to just go
play or you can go to college and then
you can pick
from the stack of job cards that are
like the better
paying jobs but then in the game of life
it's chance so
like i would end up around everybody
else anyway
who chose to wait the few steps to go to
college
um but she my mom really was like you
need something to
that that was i guess her her background
was like you need a piece of paper
you need a degree to show that you
studied and that you've
that you can do this and so i said okay
i'll
go to the fashion institute of
technology i ended up getting into
because i love crafting i love painting
i love drawing i love
making clothes and anything like that
um so i went there because it wasn't
going to put me in debt
i had an idea and i didn't even i
i couldn't put it into a conversation at
the time but something made me feel
just like the medication and
pharmaceutical game when they try to
diagnose you with something and put you
on meds
that the college education at the time
was some kind of game
that i was like i really don't want to
be in debt forever if i'm not totally
sure
like i what i want to do i feel like a
lot of
the people that i uh want to be like
didn't go through this so i want to be
like them like i don't want to go
through it either
education is important for sure and it
definitely works and it's definitely
valuable
for for others but for myself it just
didn't feel
right it didn't feel like the right path
but i went anyway listening to
my family listen to my my mom um and
that's when i got
super super depressed because i felt
like i wasn't being heard
i wasn't i would try to audition for the
dance team and they would have too many
girls because it's
filled with it's a school filled with
girls and so i wouldn't make it and so
it's like how am i expressing myself i
lost
i lost myself in um
my in in my depressions like it got to a
point where i didn't even know how
to seek i didn't even know how
to seek because i was so depressed that
i the second i would think well maybe i
can try this
no that's that's not it's gonna take too
much time it's gonna no it's not gonna
work
and so i was just wow
just like logged like i was just jammed
my
my expression was jammed and i didn't
wanna be in school
i didn't excite me to try to work
towards a degree i
wasn't trying to get it this is also a
very important lesson to
communicate around being more of a
conscious
parent because it happens across our
planet where we sort of
as the older consciousness we
instill some sort of uh in many ways
fear
into the younger consciousness that
you know if you don't get this sheet of
paper
you know and it's not just that kind of
go down this path yeah
down this path it's it's it's the
relentless sort of like
beating over the head of like the
creative expression
out of the of the of the new portal of
consciousness in
you you let it firework itself
you know type situation so your parents
specifically
have the it they do they they say that
they do it with so much
love but but it's always very much
not recognized as also something that
has a
strong tendency to diminish the spark
yeah it's the communication that you
have with your child i think because
when you have a set idea of what
something should look like
and it's not looking like that and then
you start to want
to interject and kind of for
not force it but like coerce it and and
um
mold it yes then um
it can get the the communication can get
lost
like parents are trying to chisel the
you've seen the you know the statue that
chisels itself right parents are trying
to come in and chisel
their own you know kids statue it's like
no like the expression of infinity will
chisel itself
like you have of course the role to play
to
the basic water food shelter that type
of stuff
but really the buffet of options
should be wide open and should basically
be followed by the child's interest the
montessori method as maria montessori
you know popularized it's that's the
core
and it was even back 2 thousand years
ago it's just something that is really
important
because i've also had still i'm 20
[ __ ]
eight and i still have family influences
taking the firework and being like no no
it should be like this
it's like come on time's time yeah it's
these things aren't happening and
biological things are happening it's
like
okay okay yeah okay so
the so the artistic expression almost
got locked
and i think this is also interesting
it's like this it was a sli it was like
a slingshot it felt like a slingshot it
was being pulled like where it was like
it was there
but then the trauma of my dad made me
feel insecure
and i felt kind of lost from that and
then growing up and
um not really knowing where to put
where to put it what to do because i
would be doing anything i would be
trying piano and
and all the things i stated before um
so it was like slingshotting where i was
i was getting farther and farther away
from my source and
being able to channel that and that
those those layers were being built up
uh very strongly where to the point
where i didn't
i didn't understand existence or wanted
to
like i didn't want to yeah um so i was
suicidal and then when
i was told i could take medication for
it that's when i
wanted to turn it around and uh
i think with uh i want to say i left
i i just woke up one day and didn't want
to feel that way anymore i just didn't
want to feel that weight anymore so
i said i want to try to live the way
that i
see and i'm not going to be listening to
anyone else
um and so i explained i just signed
myself out of school that day
started going around the city looking
for work
got a bunch of different part-time jobs
doing all kinds of things i worked at
the blue note jazz
club um tried to surround myself i
got a job at a production company and
tried to surround myself thinking
uh apprenticeship was what i was after
i wanted to be put in a place that
people
were doing what i would
like want to learn so that i can be
there observing just like we learn
yes uh you don't give a baby a manual on
how to walk
you it it's there and it's see or how to
talk like it's there and it's seeing and
observing and experiencing
and it starts to imitate imitate
yeah sound and and and motion
and um it's you know it's helpful when
the parents like picking them up and
this definitely plays a part is is to be
guided in a certain way but not
told like this is how this is done um
and have flexibility so once i did that
i felt more free and and felt like i
could
express myself and then ended up finding
others like a group of people out in new
jersey so i moved from the city to new
jersey because there was more space to
create and
you could have little uh like just like
this like a home studio
and and then started
uh getting ideas
like uh there was a local television
station that had an
open studio and we i was like oh i could
do something like peewee's playhouse and
um and make a show for kids because i
was always
in jobs that involved kids babysitting
or
um party entertainment anything like
that
and so my expression came out as
i'm gonna make a show and
it came to me i think one of my
brother's songs
called room of a hundred doors i got
this idea
it was almost like a vr type idea where
it's a multiverse thing where
this girl is kind of lost and she's in
the woods and she sees a box
and the idea is what is inside of a box
just a brown cardboard box and a kid
would see it as
a spaceship or a house or a grocery cart
and
with your imagination like einstein says
imagination is more important than
knowledge
you could go beyond
the chains of what reality is now to
evolve it
and um bring about something new so
going into this box the character in the
show
crawls in and then out the other side is
this magical
room of like doors
everywhere that is it's like basically
card everything's made of cardboard
and using sustainable i was like oh
that's going to be great have a low
budget use sustainable resources and
show
people through our production that we
can
um like we don't really need that much
of a budget
if we have willpower and manpower
and and love and joy and we are enjoying
ourselves
and um so i started creating like that
but then lost
the space to sports and debates
they were like oh a new manager's in the
studio and he needs to take
the studio space for for town sports
stuff and
debates so i kind of felt rejected
um and had to figure out how to express
myself again but then
in that process had met a mentor
steve weiss the wonderful magician from
new jersey he's a party entertainer
that he had responded to an ad i put out
to find creators for the show but he
kind of was like my
my right hand for the show he we just
loved each other's company and loved how
we created
so he said okay if you lost the studio
space like i want to show you
how you uh can actually monetize
and create shows for kids
for parties and birthday parties and
events and
he mentored me to do that and so for
10 years after that that's how my
expression came out i did face painting
and
balloon twisting and magic princesses
and
all these things for kids and i loved it
and then kovid but people were very
creative with how they continued to do
that with like drive-bys like i did
singing telegrams and so you could just
drive by and like
show him a few places oh yeah the
singing telegrams are the best
to just be able to be ridiculous and and
see the expression of joy that people or
horror
that people feel when they see you
coming because you have all these
balloons or you're in this costume i've
never done the mascot costume though
like people sometimes dressed as like
gorillas or bananas
as a singing telegram but i've done just
like the marilyn monroe like very
voluptuous um
like happy birthday singer or um
like for a holiday party i i wrote a
whole
um song about a lady that was turning 70
and she gave me all these facts about
her and she wanted me to like sing it to
her friends and i
wrote a whole song about her for her and
sang it
to her her event like her party and so
that's it there's endless ways like you
said endless ways of expression
um and and then i
after covid it stopped everything
because there was a flow i got onto a
flow when you express and you're just
really in it the world recognizes that
and then you become valuable to them
because they want a part of
what you're doing and so i kept getting
called and it it
became seamless where i didn't have to
like advertise much it
just came to me and then when that
stopped because of covid
i thought to myself there's a way to
refine
my expression now because
i love children i'm always going to love
entertaining and talking with children
but it it felt like there there was
something like burning in my soul
to heighten or
the quality of my entertainment i wanted
to heighten the quality of my
entertainment
and expression so
i decided to actually sit and focus and
start writing a book
about a whole other crazy experience
like i don't even i have such a hard
time
to um come compartmentalize
or to express like my life story it
would probably take me
a couple hours not even hours on the
show to write like let's
yeah let's if i wrote a book about all
the like oh my god experiences we spent
two and a half hours just talking about
like pre
a couple stories yeah a couple of the
salient stories
stories that you'd go what wow
so like those kinds of stories so
there's a five-year period
however much you want to share yeah yeah
there's a five-year period that what
like what i'm currently working on that
um is so dear to my heart and such
an important expression for me because
this story
i think as an expression was the thing
that that was like kind of backlogging
me like this is something i wanted to do
so long ago but was too afraid to
approach it because of the subject
matter
it had to do with my father had wrote a
book
in 1978 and it was called off the wall
it was written by charles wilford he was
a true crime writer
in the 70s my dad had an experience
where
in 1977 he ended up moving into an
apartment
below the son of sam who is an infamous
serial killer
and of in new york and during the year
like talk about timing and synergy of
weird experiences
the year he was doing his his killings
my dad moved into an apartment below him
and he took notice of my dad and
tried to terrorize him and and um
just focus on him too and so my dad
wrote a book about the experiences of of
helping like lead the police eventually
to him and then he was caught and then
um people wanted to know what that
experience was like
because david berkowitz had all these
writings on his apartment walls
and some of it had to do with my father
so as a child
i didn't understand what this book was
that was written because it was very
sensationalized
very uh true crime and
it scared my teachers when i would try
to do book reports on it as like an
eight-year-old
kid so i was like this is something that
might have to be
something i understand later in life so
i kind of put it away and focus on other
things
but then it came out it's like you know
what now is the time
um i started writing to david berkowitz
because i wanted to know why or
what made him
notice my dad downstairs in the
apartment building
was it something very surface like oh
they were the only two white dudes in
the building
was it that my dad was a sheriff and so
he felt threatened
i wanted to just know these questions
just for the sake
of knowing talk about seeking like that
was always as a kid like why did this
happen to my dad
but my dad wasn't around to ask so i
found this suitcase of all these
articles and
and um letters that my dad was
trying to take this story and
make it into a made-for-tv movie and at
the time they didn't have series or
netflix
streaming so he was trying to make it
into a movie or made for tv movie
and when i found all these papers and
what my dad was trying to do to pursue
the story
and he did it up till the day he died he
kept getting interviewed
news uh news
channels would call every year during
the anniversary to
to ask him what had happened and
interview him
that meant a lot to me and i was like
you know what i would like to carry that
legacy
and and figure out what had happened
with him and that will bring
working on this story will bring my dad
closer to me and like keep his spirit
alive
and i thought it was such a cool story
that i
then started reaching out to dave
berkowitz and he wrote me back
he started writing me back and we wrote
letters back and forth over a few years
and just for those that are would like
to have a re slight
small recap so so your
your father moved into the apartment
underneath
of david the same year that david was
undergoing killing seven people
yes he says he was possessed he claims
that he's possessed possessed
and then 25 years
later ish yes um
shayna's writing i was like 30 like 30
years because it's
the 40th anniversary just happened in
2017 so it was more like around i
started writing to him a couple years
before that
so it was like 30 something years 30
something years later
shayna writes you know this is again
this is very much like
a very fascinating way for source to in
it
to engage with itself because you have
basically an
entire
suite of people that are you
have the feeling of hatred and and
and don't want to do this whatsoever and
then
the sort of calling of of innocence is
forgiveness
but it's also interest and inquiry and
just
also to have the way that he'll feel
while he's
in prison to receive a letter from your
father's
yeah the daughter the daughter yeah of
him and that's why i wanted to know the
depths of it because i also had the
feeling that he it might have been
sensationalized
the story itself might have been
sensationalized of like
just the wrong place at the wrong time
and and let's do something with it
and so i wanted to ask him because he
was one of the only
people alive surrounding the case
what actually had happened because also
there were people that were reaching out
to me through facebook
saying he didn't work alone there's
there's books there's a book from maury
terry called the ultimate evil that
mentions your dad
and he did all this research that that
says he didn't work alone that there's
all this evidence that there's a
conspiracy that he was part of a group
that
he was the one to take the fall and
nothing is provable and i
just became so curious and wanted to go
to the source
that's really what it became it's like i
wanted to go to the source
and then people start to confuse it with
like well why are you
giving it the time of day why are you
why do you care what he thinks
uh what like the idea of truth
um it wasn't even about seeking the
truth it was just about
seeing like i ended up then going to
visit him i sat with him like
as close as we are now there's no plas
there's no plexiglas
you don't it's not like you make phone
calls like that it's just
open space where two people are sitting
and talking
and the vibration like we were talking
about vibration it doesn't matter what's
coming out of the your mouth as far as
what word choice you're using
people receive an energy and a vibration
and that's what i wanted to know
what it felt like to sit with someone
like that because
what i had discovered before i went to
visit was that he
became a born-again christian and
felt that he found source he calls it
jesus
and he felt he found jesus and became
a man of god that that wants to spread
light
and so in my mind i saw it as like it's
like alchemy because he really
was of uh considered a model inmate like
he was very
like a very sweet um prisoner
where he didn't cause trouble he he did
what he had to do
he always had he always worked his job
and and appreciated it
it's the alchemical pulse from murder to
finding jesus
to to well to like i don't know where
the story comes from of
enlightenment where it's someone it says
like first man chops wood carries water
then
man finds enlightenment and chops wood
and carries water
yeah i believe that's a zen's tradition
yeah so so that's the kind of the
way i saw him was like for the first 10
years he was in prison he was in torment
because he didn't know just like
i the first thing i wrote to him was
i'm very depressed i'm the daughter of
someone you once knew
i wanted to write to you because i
wanted to understand why someone like
you in your position would even wake up
in the morning
what inspires you to want to keep living
when you can kill yourself
you know you're never going to get out
you've been in there for so long you
have no concept of what's outside
of those walls how do you keep a smile
on your face and
and then more so even want to help
others who are in there
to to inspire them to want to live
and that's i i approached it where i was
writing like i
was that like of a young child like with
a childlike wonder
of i feel like i'm in prison in my own
body
you're in double prison where you're in
prison
with your like where your soul is in
your body and your body is in
a structure that you can't leave so like
what
what is what is it so that's really what
i was seeking was i was trying to go
in and find the light uh
of his soul because he's still alive
like he's still a person that's alive
and
um there's the yin yang there's always
like a little darkness in the
in the the light and a little light in
the darkness so i was
uh looking to be an alchemist
uh and express the alchemy of taking a
story that really scares people
and then putting a twist on it that
inspires them
to see that wow if i could perceive
something like that
then anything is possible i started
contacting even the people i met around
pursuing the book i talked to one of the
victims carl dinero
who's writing his own book about he was
shot but survived
he has a plate in his head and his
daughter went to brooklyn film
school to make a movie about his
experience of what he went through
so it's like i call it shrapnel all the
people
that reverberated um through the
experience of like this one nugget
of a story there's all these other
stories that span out that have to do
with this like it's like a little energy
tornado
and then all the things that are
affected like even it's like kind of
raining out here
those are still stories to be told yeah
that's that's a really important
visualization
of how a experience
like you said reverberates out and then
makes another
whole web of
interrelated ex stories that are told
like the
the the like the so
along with the seven murders there were
six serious wounded
wounded and one of them was the one with
this carl yeah carl
and like there so there's like art made
about that
and then there's art like you're making
two things his daughter made a movie
he's writing a book he's publishing a
book i have
a book that's being published and my dad
had a book so like there's all these
it's it's like different perspectives
around
it's a prism of perspectives around this
main
idea of the same story and that's what i
was always irked
i had to pursue it because every time
out of all the projects i wanted to
pursue
like want to do music but then kovid
stopped being able to go out live and
being able to meet and so
that's back burner but then the book you
could write a book you could write the
story
by yourself with minimal
interaction and i really wanted to give
it the chance to
get it out of me and out of my backlog
because that is the like oh gee thing
that inspired me to be like
i want to perform because this happened
and it makes me want to
talk about it and i feel like that was
that was worth pursuing even if it's
like
such a strange topic and
like it's it's like the night sky it's
so dark but there's
there's stars that make it so beautiful
if you just focus on the stars instead
of the dark matter that's
that's in the sky yeah there's
simultaneously the hot
iron ball like bernardo castro says that
is you know coming creatively out that
you know that must be
shared like with what you're discussing
with the project and yet at the same
time
it's so strange like there's all the
stories of kind of like the archetype of
the
child that had the experience of
their parents like successful business
or some sort of traumatic
scenario which then is like carrying
this torch or this
baton to share and like kind of
it's also balanced with like is this
really me is this really what i'm here
to do and so like
yeah so kind of yeah and we talked a lot
also in that two and a half hours about
like the whole [ __ ] ship
mentality right that's what i just
wanted to like
i'm gonna oh it's always gonna come
around this is the just the perfect
timing to
to get it out and express it
so that's what i did and and it will be
coming soon
yeah this is a nut story it's like one
of
i don't know like two like really nuts
parts of your yeah trajectory two out of
infinity
yeah there's a lot of yeah
yeah yeah there's there's there's
several components in the trajectory
that were
seen as treasures now on the other side
of massive you know traumas
so yeah let's um let's let's jump into
some of the
the upcoming expressions music
musically so you've been profoundly
influenced
by ram das
be here now
yeah that book that is like uh
they call it a bathroom read it's the
kind of book that you can literally
just scroll it and open to any page
and read that and just go think about
that for a while
and you don't have it's not like you
have to read in like put a bookmark in
it you just you can open it at any time
any point
the toilet read not in the quality
that's the complete opposite
it's so quality but be here now
i just loved that concept and so i wrote
a song
that is percussive it's a percussive
song
that i love to express and i love to
perform
i'm so excited for drink some this
all right and so it's percussive too so
yeah you could join along if you
if you so choose to feel the rhythm
coming through you while you listen to
it
let's see
so something like that i hear music in
the echo
of this water falling down and the day
that you are hearing
i'll be gone from this year town you
will find me in the city
you won't find me in the streets just
look up to see me flying
no soaring anywhere i please wherever i
please wherever i please
and you oh you gotta listen for echo
echo echo
and i hear that sound you gotta be
here now i go dancing when i'm walking
cause this world can get me down you
should try it too
you'll feel it from your feet up to your
crown
people tell us that we're crazy people
tell us that we're mad
but mentally they're lazy grasping
anything they can think they can think
they can
and you oh you gotta listen for echo
echo echo
and hear that sound you gotta be
here now be now i'm just here to say
it's gonna be all right
if you feel me now
live your dreams and fight
if you're feeling this you know exactly
what to do
it's not up to me or up to him
it's up to you it's up to you
it's up to you it's up to you and you
oh you gotta listen for echo echo echo
and i hear that sound you gotta be
here now be now be here now
v now be here
yeah this is definitely one of my faves
i really love it thank you so much for
allowing me to express that and for
receiving it
as clearly as you did before and do now
and i hope that everyone that heard it
just now
feels the
quality of transmission regardless of
the perfection
that was pure expression in the moment
right here right now
yeah that that's one of the
mimetic vibes especially via music
that i feel will be really
catalytic on the awakening because
it's packaged together in such a
rhythmically
satisfying melodic way and that makes
people want to sing along and the whole
idea of
sing-along is
it's mission critical for getting the
memes
that are disseminated to stick and to
become popular in the culture
and so you really produce something here
that
i'm excited to see how some of our
awesome peeps here and la will hopefully
be able to help
be catalytic we'll see if i'm excited
for
for my tribe i've always been looking to
attract my tribe
of creators to create with um
just like because this this book has
been a practice of creating in
a bubble of just the process of getting
it out is
just alone just a being a sole writer
but being a musician you can create it's
so
much fun to express and align
those vibrations with others um because
it's
it's like an amplification like all of
our energies when they're aligned
doing that same thing in that focused
space
um amplifies the message amplifies the
vibration
and um yeah i
it's it's affirmation like i love
singing things that you know
if people are gonna have it stuck like
they call ear worms if people are gonna
have those things stuck in their minds
have
lyrics or words or expressions stuck in
their minds
i would love for them to be
positive and something that
makes it feel good to say over and over
and over
yeah it's a
straight up namaste right straight up
just bow to that beautiful divine
firework expression that was
adore it i really hope yeah zeb
kyle i really hope that some of our
friends want to embark on producing this
with you because i adore it and i think
it
again i think it just makes the
love spread
through not only your beautiful voice
but also the way that you put it
together
rhythmically is is i think that that's
really the key and the sing-along that
type of thing is
is going to be critical for
disseminating music and other content
that then
catalyzes the largest scale butterfly
effect of awakening
yeah for sure thank you so
much thank you so much yeah
i'm so jacked that was just
just be here now now
that's i like the dancing down the
street it's a good visual like i go
dancing when i'm walking because this
world can get me down
whenever i'm feeling down if i usually
start dancing
gives me life i totally
i totally agree with that vibe like yeah
you gotta go inward first to go
uh
yeah you're right though it's like can
you trigger
the dancy free flowy
state
you know just walking on the street
can you pick up a little bit of beat
yeah
some kind of the rhythm listening for
the rhythm of the
street sounds uh car honks like the
timing of
that if you're really aware it's a good
meditation it's an active meditation
um oftentimes you'll you'll also have
feedback and get
get like a communication back from your
surroundings
it's almost like it the awareness
becomes aware of your awareness of
it and so like i'll give an example of
something that happened yesterday i was
thinking a thought
and as i was thinking it i look up at
and that moment a billboard
is the response like i'm having a
conversation
my awareness without words is having a
conversation with
the outward awareness of like looking at
me
or like focused upon me and that is
that is so mad it's magic it just it
feels like magic
yeah it's that feeling that you get when
you watch a magician as a little kid
like you just can't figure out how
you kind of know that there's something
to it but
you just you're like what oh my god
oh my god we are
very much so in our own
l chemistry right our own little
alchemical
ascensionary firework
yeah and it's so cool that you can you
can see
you can see it you know mirroring
feedbacking
all the time but one has to
get inward first to the point where they
recognize
themselves as that infinite creator
as that source that expresses all of the
possible
combinations and then therefore
the awareness no longer becomes
something that's
siloed and egoic but it becomes
something that's
shared and eternal and then
everything from there flows harmonically
and a level of identity has become
identified with your true nature and not
with what is
under the veil because the veil
is what creates so much of the planetary
disaster it's likely the
most upstream target of
the planetary awakening is to dissolve
as much ego
as possible especially in positions of
leadership
yeah and music like that does it like
can you imagine you know like we love
like
the u.n or whatever just like singing be
here now right
you know like at the general assembly
like i love stuff like that
that's and like you know having a little
like also them like playing the drum
circle
like you know and collectively singing
and
absolutely like how much more peace does
that catalyze how much less
stress all that type of stuff that's
that's the future that
we envision as an enlightened
collective dreamed planet aware souls
dream
dream dream dream
this is great okay i think i think
that's pretty solid
um so eventually you'll also
be embarking on your joy on a bus which
is very exciting that's so future future
talk
so yeah we'll put a bookmark on the joy
on the bus
that's the only job that i will ever
have is joy on a bus
because the idea between love peace and
paint
what i did that was my company love
peace and pain for face painting party
entertainment
and then with what i
express in the book about law of
attraction and
um and alchemy and all that
uh job on a bus is like the way to
tour that and to be able to bring it
from place to place i always envision
having like an rv
i don't know why i don't know why but i
keep having this vision of traveling on
an rv
and then getting off the bus and setting
up some kind of like mobile stage
fire dancing and people and just having
an attraction to gather people so that
when we
draw them in they ask what we're doing
and ask what it is
and our joy from our bus the joy in a
bus
we have websites or information to share
with them
to show them that there's other ways of
being
like being a traveler you don't have to
be fixed into one place there's ways of
tapping into your own collective
to be able to travel from state to state
or country to country when
everything opens so yeah that's just
future stuff
is the job joy on a bus
this phenomenon became so much more
popular
i love it it's there's like more and
more people that
sort of tiny homes yeah and like yurts
and yeah and i
i specifically love how you have the
focus on the bringing the joy on the bus
because you're not just a traveler
on the road but there's now more and
more people that are sort of putting
together their own
unique combination of what they think
joy on a bus is and bringing that out
to like setting up stages like you're
describing and having
festivities and music and and
it's a real that's really exciting
because it's it's probably
one of the cool archetypes of what it's
like
to commune with your true nature and
then literally bring joy not just
on a one-person level but bring joy on a
bus yeah well
ken ken keezy he did he that's where i
think i got the idea from a long time
ago is that
ken kesey and i think the he called it
ken keisee in the band of merry makers
it would just be a bunch of people that
got on the bus it was the hippie culture
in the 60s when they started dosing
people with acid
and they would go from town to town
painting the bus like all of these
people would get off the bus
they'd paint it up they'd paint
themselves and people would wonder what
they're doing and be like oh you're
hippies
but they would bring awareness to
something that was happening that was
growing that was changing
and then they would just get back on and
and go to the next town and and do that
and
he wrote the one flew over a cuckoo's
nest uh ken
kesey and a bunch of other cool
electric kool-aid acid kool-aid
something like that but such
a concept to have your little community
traveling with you
and i saw that as something that was
valuable
and and and very um
a a good way of expressing
and sharing information like even with
the internet
it's still like it's sure we could make
a bunch of
websites and try to mobile in person joy
yeah when you see something like that
driving down the street
you you kind of want to know what it is
where are they going how to go commune
with some joy from a bus that'd be funny
yeah it'd be playful yeah
yeah if it's playing music and bubbles
colors anything that's
attracting the light attracting that
kind of
of things got me at bubbles yeah
that's great yeah also you singing
yeah yeah that'd be so good yeah paint
all that cool stuff
colors infinite expressions yeah yeah
exactly
blank canvases and color yeah for sure
this is uh
it's very much making sure that the
pablo picasso child like awe
is retained throughout your adolescence
and adulthood
so that you don't become a corporate
zombie in a straight jacket
and don't fear worry that's the key
thing is
what helped me express was to work on
letting go
and releasing the fear of of what it
looks like how it sounds
if it's perfect and
dr seuss my favorite quote is be who you
are
and say what you feel because those who
mind don't matter
and those who matter don't mind
so it's it's
feels so
joyous to be able to connect with
yourself
without that doubt and that fear and
that worry
that something is off with that
if you feel connected to yourself then
it's like go express
yeah there's nothing sexier than the
courage to be exactly the
unique expression firework of infinity
the youiest you you can be
yeah the you you can be yeah i love that
what a great way to rap be the youst you
you can be i love that
because the was it the law of one
there's only one you
yeah there's only one you
yeah so be it yep amen
perfect yay i love it
yes i love it yeah
i feel like we need to dance like a
dance track we need an outro
you know you know we we actually used to
have a
uh intro and outro music from our first
like
500 or so episodes
and so we may bring that back once we
have
some of sort of
something that we like you know we might
produce our own little
like dj track that kind of incorporates
those
remember like we were saying like let it
happen
forever forever ever you know we might
just grab a bunch of different
stuff that that that we like across and
put it all together into because there's
a lot of good ones that already sort of
exist across
different popular music as their
choruses and just to know how to stitch
them together
in a way that's exciting yeah yeah
um well then i have a lot of toys a lot
of musical toys
to bring next time like looper pedals
and things that
sing and it loops and then we can add
layers to it i love that yeah we'll play
with that that's a great idea
yay music production yeah and as
as as francis lucille says uh eternal
fireworks
contemplate that thank you so much for
having me here
appreciate it beyond words be on time
beyond quality beyond value beyond any
expression
of the commu that i could communicate
with my
my words i really appreciate being here
it's magical
we reflect back that gratitude
for this beautiful
divine synchronization
yeah yeah those two and a half hours
before we even the show that was like
some of the longest
like you know pow wow pre-show pow wow
we we ever have so that was
also a good indicator it's like yeah
there's just so much beauty to unpack
so that was so fun awesome everyone
sheena craig you can find her links in
the bio below
her youtube profile go and check that
out also her instagram and her website
go and check those links out
and be on the lookout for the book also
for the music drops
and let us know how i feel about the
conversation in the comments below we'd
love to hear from you drop us a comment
if the video brought you value give it a
like subscribe if you haven't share the
video with other people that you think
would find it exciting and useful
and that is all much
lower that's it for our show
so we must go